thank you for being a friend
traveled down the road and back again
how soul soothing that is john mayer
performed the golden girls theme song in
tribute to betty white during cnn's new
year's eve special it was beautiful now
the classic sitcom went on for seven
seasons starting in the 1980s and e.t
was the only entertainment show ever
invited to the set
thank you for being a friend
i don't want to spoil a surprise but in
a couple of weeks someone in this room
is going to know how to yodel
i read the script and just flipped about
it and b arthur and rooney mcclanahan
both had the same reaction do you know
what i hate doing most after a party
trying to find your underwear in the big
pile
these aren't old people they you don't
self-destruct once you pass 55. we're
all just as as vital and sensual and and
nutty and
good and bad as anybody else stan came
by and stayed with me brought me food
held me
showed me that special part of himself
right there in the waiting room
do you know what a privilege it is at
this end of a career i mean after being
in the business this long to work with
three people no matter what you throw
out you get something wonderful back to
back why rose nylon
wow that cake is in the shape blanche we
know what it is
i thought it was in the shape of florida
can you believe at 63 years old betty
was the eldest of the golden girls she
played the sweet but not so sharp rose
my father told stan that he had to marry
me i was pregnant
you had a blow gun wedding
well this season uh we're writing the
other girls out and rose is doing it in
one it's just gonna be you know the
betty white show and then
sorry about that no that's the real
betty coming forward you see rose has
disappeared
the show premiered in 1985 and is still
a hit with fans when much of the country
was locked down due to the pandemic more
than 11 million hours of the golden
girls was streamed in april 2020 alone
they are the hottest two little words in
all the whole world for me to say
not tonight
[Music]
betty originally auditioned for the role
of blanche but producers felt the part
was too similar to her character from
the mary tyler moore show so she became
rose and won her third emmy for the
golden girls in fact every single
actress won during the show's seven year
run everybody on the golden girls has a
as a golden girl of her own i think
now next year we're all up for grabs we
start all over again isn't that
wonderful you want to see my van's cap
kaka as long as i don't have to show you
mine
i've been so blessed it's such a great
experience
but betty's favorite role wife to
husband alan ludden who knows
might be better than the first
[Music]
love of my life when you've had the best
who needs the rest why betty white my
alan
their love story began on the game show
password where alan was the host well
it's nice to see you again nice to see
you that's where i met my husband and
that's where we got married it took me a
year to get smart to marry allen when he
kept asking practically from the
beginning and i kept saying no no no for
love came just in time
i found you just in time
we went to dinner
and he gave me this beautiful wedding
ring
with diamonds all around it and the gold
wedding ring and of course as any
red-blooded american girl would do i got
mad because i kept saying no i won't no
i won't marry it and i gave it back to
him well did he take it back to the
jeweler no he put it on a gold chain
around his neck so every time i saw him
there was that blinking wedding ring he
said you're to wear it someday you might
as well get used to it
so sure enough after after a year i i
did the ladies celebrity and pastor this
week is a lady that i married four years
ago today happy anniversary betty white
allen was actually betty's third husband
she became the loving stepmother to his
three kids and chose not to have
children of her own no i've never
regretted it i didn't choose to have
children because i'm focused on my
career and
i just don't think as compulsive as i am
that i could manage both betty cherished
every moment of her life with alan who
after nearly two decades together became
sick from stomach cancer we knew for
almost two years that we were on a
dead-end street but we just made up our
minds that we were going to make the
most of the time we had and as a result
we didn't spend
a lot of time beating our breasts and
saying why is this happening
and we just
you can't handle anything well all the
time but for the most part it worked
pretty well
allen passed away in 1981 betty never
remarried but over the years she did
develop a pretty heavy crush is there
one thing out there that betty white
still wants to do
robert redford
robert redford robert redford robert
redford and yes the legendary actor was
on her mind just days before her passing
we spoke to betty ahead of what would
have been her 100th birthday and once
again she told et her big wish was quote
robert redford i would be so embarrassed
if i ever met him
he never calls he never writes i tried
she just never responded upon learning
of her death the 85 year old told et she
made us all laugh including me i had a
crush on her too i can't imagine being
loved by anybody better
that was the only time that betty was at
a loss for words when we started talking
about robert redford i mean the crush
was so cute and so really had one back
on her i just love it we love it
you